To me,
the mentality is a really simple one and
an assistant.
The confidence comes from preparation,
you know?
So when the game's on the line,
I'm not asking myself to do something
that I haven't done it thousands of
times before.
Right.
So what are prepare?
I know what I'm capable of doing.
I know what I'm comfortable doing and I
know what I'm not comfortable doing it.
Right.
And so in those moments,
if it looks like um,
ice cold or not nervous,
it's because I've done it thousands of
times before.
So what's one more time.
Okay.
So that leads me to talk about,
and a lot of,
uh,
this colby toward this year in Asia is
we reiterate the Mamba mentality,
you know?
Can you talk a little bit about what the
Mamba mentality is because that's
something that's been developing over,
not,
I don't want to say 20 years.
It's been developing for 35 years since
you were a little kid.
That Mamba mentality because you didn't
start working when you got the damn.
Yeah.
You started working when you were at
lower merion,
when you were in Italy,
when you were five.
When you're playing NERF nerf
basketball.
So talking to house,
talk about the development of the Mamba
mentality.
Uh,
the pillars,
the five pillars of this Mamba
mentality,
and then we'll kind of break it down.
Well,
I mean,
overall,
you know,
the idea is a very simple one.
And you know,
the Mamba mentality simply means trying
to be the best version of yourself.
That's what the mentality means.
It means every day you're trying to
become better.
And it's a constant quest.
It's an infinite quest.
So starting at the age of two,
when I first started playing the game
and on and on and on,
I always ask questions.
Always tried to get better every single
day.
Learn more than you're asking questions
at two.
Oh Dude,
I was time.
You'd be surprised.
Like some people,
like my kids at two could do a lot of
things.
At two.
I could dribble a basketball,
I can shoot a basketball and a nerve.
We got the house and I would go to
practice with my father.
I would observe my father.
Um,
I sit and watch games with him.
Is He your first coach?
Um,
yeah.
Man,
I guess you could say that,
you know,
a lot of things I learned by being just
being around the game.
Right.
So by the age of six,
I was already strategizing versus other
six year olds.
You know,
they just six I figured out six year
olds couldn't dribble with their left
hand.
So I said,
okay,
a lot of a lot of 12 year olds can't
dribble with their [inaudible] would
imagine six.
So like I was playing in the six year
old kids,
I would make them dribble with their
left because I knew they couldn't.
And so the dribble off the rear foot,
I'd pick it up,
lay it up,
do it again,
drove off it,
pick it up later.
So at six years old it had 63 points
and,
and uh,
I remember my,
so your six year old,
six year old self could beat,
you're a 38 year old selfies.
You only scored 16 the last game.
Yeah,
no,
but I could do it with my left toe.
So that's a problem.
But um,
but yeah,
I mean it's,
listen,
I just constantly looked for things to
learn from.
And you know,
very observant.
When you,
when you talk about this love,
when does it develop what you,
did you like it when you were five or is
it something that kind of gradually not
to,
it was born.
I was born to play basketball,
you know what I mean?
And I played a lot of different sports.
Um,
but nothing brought me the sense of,
of,
of peace and of escape.
You know,
that the game of basketball,
is it an escape when you get on the
court?
Is that your zen time?
You're,
you're,
you're solid two times,
even though it's a team working.
Yeah.
When I need that escape,
it's there for me.
Right.
When I need a friend,
it's there for me.
You know what?
I need to vent and don't dog in the Mama
comes to stare,
you know?
So yeah,
the game is absolutely everything.
When,
when you,
when we talk about trying to get kids to
be passionate,
I don't think every kid,
I don't think your situation is the
norm.
Not every kid is,
knows they're passionate too,
and we're fine.
Right.
How do kids find that passion then?
Well,
I,
you know,
I think that's because you,
you embraced it right away.
I think experience,
we try to put them in different things,
try to expose them to as many things as
possible and then see if there's one
thing that connects with them,
you know?
Because if it does,
you don't have to tell them to do it,
you know,
whether it's writing or painting or
drawing,
you know,
if they have that passion,
you don't have to tell them they're go
off and do it because it's just fun.
He'd rather do that than anything else.
So,
but as parents,
it's our job to just expose them to as
many things as possible and see which
one they gravitate to the most.
It's interesting because you,
you talked about kits,
right?
Originally we were talking about you and
now you're talking about your kids and
their passions.
Do you,
do you kind of feel that passion for
them and then say,
hey,
let's go play some basketball or
volleyball or let's go swimming.
We expose them to all kinds of,
I mean,
they play a lot of different sports.
They do a lot of things creatively,
you know,
in writing and things like that and
designing and um,
you just sit back and you just watch
which one they moved to and then it's
our responsibility as parents to try to
set them up for success as much as we
possibly can.
Do you want them to play basketball?
I want them to find whatever it is that
they're passionate about.
Like whenever they feel like their
purposes,
then that's what I want them to do.
Do they love basketball then?
My youngest one she does.
She wants to,
she wants to play.
She wants me to teach you how to play
this summer.
And our eldest is really into
volleyball,
so,
and um,
but we'll see.
You know,
passions tend to change.
So you're going to get into volleyball
now?
Well,
yeah.
I mean my sister was a great volleyball
player,
so we have a teacher in a family.
Is there,
is there one moment where you can say it
defined your passion for basketball?
Is there a story or moment when you said
Dan that was,
that was it,
that was like when I felt really
passionate.
No,
it doesn't,
it never leaves.
You never leaves,
you know,
the game was just a part of me.
Um,
so it never leaves.
Even now that I'm retired,
you know,
I,
everything that I've learned from the
game of basketball I've carried over
into life,
you know,
like basketball has helped me be a
better person,
a better friend,
a better well because there's life
lessons that are within the game,
like communication,
like unselfishness,
like attention to detail and um,
empathy and compassion.
Like all those things are in the game.
And,
uh,
as an athlete,
if we are aware of those things,
it helps us become better human human
beings.
And you can apply that toward your
posts,
basketball days,
retirement into your business world.
Sure.
Future ventures.
I mean you can apply,
you know,
I was applying that,
um,
even while I was playing just in life
outside of the game and even more so now
you know,
and building a business and all these
things kind of culture you want to have,
um,
you know,
all those things are or directly learn
from the game of basketball.
A next step is the next pillar.
Be Obsessive,
obsessive.
That's I think a,
I think a lot of people equate that with
you.
You know,
colby is obsessive in a lot of things.
We've been doing this for what,
eight years now?
Asia tour,
you know,
I've been with you for a long way.
I,
the one moment that stands out out of,
we've done,
I don't know how many dumb,
we've done 800 events.
The one time was 4:00 AM we went up to
practice at 4:00 AM and that was your
idea to do it.
But you know,
all these Nike people are like,
no,
that's not,
that's not do that.
And then you're like,
let's do it at 4:00 AM.
So you've got security,
you've got brand marketing,
sports marketing going,
no,
that's not good.
You're like,
let's do it because that's your
assessment is right to me.
It just makes complete sense and not to
us.
Oh boy.
I don't want to like
see we all right.
Usually I'm sleeping at 4:00 AM you're,
you're working out.
So talk about that.
Okay?
So if,
if,
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be,
to do that,
you have to practice,
you have to train,
right?
You want to train as much as you can,
as often as you can.
So if you get up at 10 in the morning,
train at 11,
right?
12 say 12 and Trina,
12 train for two hours,
12 to,
to,
um,
you have to let your body recover.
So you eat,
recovered,
whatever.
You get back out,
you train,
start training and at six train from six
to eight,
right?
And now you go home,
shower,
eat dinner,
and you go to bed.
You wake up and do it again,
right?
Those are two sessions right now.
Imagine you wake up at three you train
at four 46 come home,
breakfast,
relaxed.
So,
so now you're back at it again,
nine to 11 right,
relax.
And now all of a sudden you're back at
it again.
Two to four and now you're back at it
again,
you know,
seven to nine.
Look how much more training I have done
by simply starting at four.
All right.
And so now you do that and as the years
go on,
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger.
And by year five or six,
it doesn't matter what kind of work
they're doing in summer,
they're never going to catch up cause
they're five years behind.
Right.
So it makes sense to get up and start
your day early because you can get more
work in.
Is that genetic or is that something
you,
you ingrained in trained yourself?
No,
it was just you that for me it was just,
it was just common sense.
Like I can,
I can,
if I start earlier,
I can train more hours and I know the
other guys aren't doing it because I
know what their training schedule is.
Right.
So I know if I do this consistently over
time,
it's the gaps just going to widen and
widen and widen and widen and widen and
they won't be able to get that bag.
So it,
to me it was just common sense.
I'm like thinking,
how can I get an advantage?
Oh,
start earlier.
Yeah,
let's do that.
When did you start doing that?
Man?
High School.
And we started,
my first class in high school is seven
at seven 45.
I usually get to the gym around 5:00 AM
and I'd played before school and then
school starts and then with you at 5:00
AM my coach and my coach was show up and
we'd do all these basketball drills.
Right.
So just you and your coach?
Just me and my coach.
And sometimes it would just be me and
the janitor who's still there today.
And um,
and um,
and then I play at lunchtime.
You get a medal.
I hooked him up with a few things,
but I played during lunch and then
practice after and then go home,
do my schoolwork and then watch a bunch
of game film and Games on TV and study,
study film.
Was that the only thing you've been
assessed about basketball?
Well,
until recently?
Yeah,
until recently.
Yeah.
Basketball dominated,
you know,
my,
uh,
my entire life more than 30 years when,
when I,
when I brought it up like what are you,
is it genetic or you just learned it?
I mean,
how,
how did that idea even come up?
Because that's obviously a pillar of
Mamba mentality.
The obsessiveness is just like you said,
I'm going to get up at four,
everybody's get up at six.
If everybody's going to get up at four,
I'm going to get him in too.
Right,
right.
How do you,
how do you develop that or what do you,
what do you learn that from?
Well,
I think it's just,
it's just a matter of what's important
to you,
what's important to you for whatever
reason.
You know,
I felt like,
um,
I didn't feel good about myself.
If I wasn't doing everything I could to
be the best version of myself.
If I felt like I left anything on the
table,
um,
it would eat away at me.
I wouldn't be able to look myself in the
mirror,
right?
So the reason why I can retire now and
be completely comfortable about it
because I know that I've done everything
I could to be the best basketball player
I could be.
Um,
and so that's where it comes from for
me.
You can't leave any stone unturned,
but the important thing to understand is
you can't,
you can't short change yourself.
Like you're,
you're not cheating anybody but
yourself.
I mean,
you're tired.
You're literally this far away from the
line.
Why would you not go that extra to touch
the line?
Right?
So if I let them get away with that,
right?
All of a sudden he starts maybe a cheat,
something over here,
right?
And not give his best over here and I
give his best over.
Then as years go on,
he's going to be extremely,
it's not going to reach his full
potential because he's been taking these
little shortcuts that just add up.
Adam,
Adam add up and you can't let that
happen.
Our job as teachers,
as mentors,
as inspires,
it's our responsibility to hold them
accountable to those things.
The funny part is we were were just
talking about this kid,
we in the back and coke.
He's like,
I bet you that kid will never,
ever missed the line again.
You're not going to happen
because of that wasn't no way that
that's you being obsessive,
but teaching obsessiveness because
that's,
that's what you got to be.
Right.
Do you have to be obsessive to get to
that level and everything you do,
details don't waste time.
Do it.
Right.
Perfection.
Yeah.
I mean it's really simple.
It was like whatever you're doing at
that moment is what you're doing at that
moment.
You know?
It's like that's where the obsessiveness
is.
Having the attention to detail for this
action that you are performing at the
time you're performing it.
And if you can have that kind of focus,
you can't help but to have a certain
level of obsession or attention to
detail.
Moving on to the third pillar is a to be
realm relentless that we know you for.
You know,
we see you on TV being relentless,
first quarter,
second quarter,
third quarter,
fourth quarter attack,
attack,
never letting your teammates slack off,
attack.
How do you get that?
Talk about what is,
what is the meaning of relentlessness to
you?
Well,
this is to never to be unyielding.
Never give an inch to anything like
you're always going after it.
Always going after all he's going after
it.
And if there's a challenge that ensues,
oh good.
I want to see how I stack up to that.
So you'd go after and go after it and
it's just,
um,
it's fun.
It's like you get a chance to compete
against opponents and you get a chance
to see where you stack up against them.
I was like,
I want to see it.
Maybe I'm not good enough today with
that.
That's fine.
I'll be good enough the next time I see
you though,
you know,
and you get a chance to always measure
yourself and um,
it's,
it's just fun to do that.
So I guess that's where relentlessness
comes from.
Is it something that's also learned or
ingrained or is it something you kind of
learned over time?
Um,
because these things that we talk about
in a Mama and tality,
uh,
you know,
for you,
it's second nature.
It's not for a lot of people,
right?
A lot of it is,
is trained or it's not God given know
Aye.
I mean,
it as well though,
because I mean,
I had a year of playing,
like when I played basketball in Italy,
I was taller than everybody else and
faster,
um,
like the age of 11,
I came back to America to play
basketball and it was not the same thing
because kids were bigger,
stronger.
And so I went through a summer of
playing basketball in America.
Why didn't score one point,
it was one league.
I didn't score one point and it was
devastating.
Um,
but I had to,
no,
I'm not giving up.
It's not what to happen.
So you bounced back and you keep
playing.
You keep practicing,
keep practicing.
But I mean it wasn't handed to me.
You didn't score one point,
not one.
I mean not even a free flow.
And you are zero.
You are held 11,
11.
Well you were playing against 25 year
olds.
No,
I was playing against 11 grade.
I was playing against.
It's hard to believe why.
I know,
I know.
But I was playing against 11 year olds
and I didn't score one point.
And then what was that?
Did that uh,
it,
it hurt you or you?
Yeah,
it was very embarrassing because,
you know,
my father was a Philadelphia basketball
legend.
My uncle was in Philadelphia,
basketball legend.
And now here I am,
this kid,
like he's really big knee pads and I'm
walking around and I can't score it
anything.
So it was like really embarrassing.
That drove you.
Of course it did.
Of course it didn't.
I vowed to be much,
much better.
So you live for those moments where
you're embarrassed when you're down.
People kick,
you don't let you score.
Those are the moments that drive you.
Well,
I mean those are the moments that occur,
right?
So whatever moments occur,
good,
bad or indifferent,
I can use those moments to propel me
forward,
use those as fuel to,
um,
help me be a better player.
Is there a moment in your Mba career
where you felt like you didn't hit that
mark and that was a huge transition for
you?
Yeah,
I always felt like I missed the marks,
um,
in the league.
Um,
what were some of the down moments for
you in basketball?
Losing to the Celtics in the finance in
2008.
I mean,
that was tough and that hurt me too.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
it was brutal at night in the hotel room
after we lost,
just thinking to myself,
I may never win another championship.
Like I might've just like,
this is it.
It's too hard to get back here.
Maybe it's not in the car is to win
another one.
And so I go through that night or being
mad.
Then the next morning I wake up and they
start thinking,
Nah,
I gotta fix this.
So where did it go wrong?
Why did we lose or we weren't tough
enough.
Okay.
Weren't tough enough.
Whose responsibility is that to make the
team?
It's mine.
All right.
So now I have to start figuring out how
I'm going to lead this team differently
to make sure that when we get to the
finals the next time we were tough and
ready for this challenge.
And um,
that's,
that's how you bounce back from those
moments.
That was 2008 2008 2008 against the
Celtics.
I mean,
all of Laker nation was hurt because
especially because it was against the
Celtics,
right?
Kid was paint,
Celtics.
He can't lose celtics.
Come on,
God.
Sounds like,
well,
you know,
because also that was there.
That was their like 17th right.
For their,
for their organization.
And only talk about that.
I'll talk about that.
And then you bounced back the next year
against a Orlando,
Orlando or [inaudible] got her revenge
against the Celtics in 2010.
The beating the Celtics feel better than
beating Orlando?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I grew up such a lakers fan and so like
the Lakers and Celtics rivalries Hatim
everything hate him.
We can't,
there's just no way I can be on a team
when a Lakers team that loses to the
Celtics twice.
No.
You know,
it's a funny,
in in Asia,
me being here in Asia to a lot of,
a lot of fans are fans of a player and
they,
they loved that player and subsequently
late,
they loved that team that,
that player plays for.
But growing up in the states,
if you grew up in Philly,
you are a sixers fan.
Right?
And then if you grew up in La,
you were a lakers fan.
You are also a dodgers fan.
And at the time you are a rams fan.
You are affiliated with your city and
then the city that you hate,
it was your arch enemy.
So if you a Laker fan,
you just hate the Celtics and you hate
every team,
every team that loses you root for every
team against the Celtics.
No question.
Yeah,
the enemy of my enemy is my friend.
You just want to see them do bed.
Yeah,
just do batch.
If you,
if you were a dodger fan,
you just want to see the giants lose.
Right.
So it's not necessarily good Karma,
but yeah.
But when you lost to the Celtics,
then you beat him again.
That moment that that's relentless
because you come get them back,
coming back,
coming back and you had to come back and
beat the case on their court.
Can't give up and then it was there.
It was that,
was that a big moment for you beating,
beating the Celtics?
It was used,
you know,
because,
we seen,
I've seen us as a team grow so much from
2008 POW Lamar,
you know,
all our guys,
like how much we have grown since the
last time you faced this team.
And uh,
I couldn't be any more proud of them.
You know,
it wasn't even about me.
It was about sitting back and watching
us as a group and we just accomplished
this amazing thing.
And uh,
now we can all enjoy it together.
So
moving on to the next pillar is to be
resilient.
Um,
I remember this time last year you came
and,
uh,
we did a premier for a,
a movie you did moves and a big,
a big part of that movie was talking
about your injury and coming back to be
resilient.
Uh,
take us back to that day against a
Phoenix,
right.
Your Gear Achilles is golden state.
It was,
it was,
it was hard,
man,
because the Achilles injury is the worst
injury for an athlete.
It's like the word.
So it's like the kiss of death.
And when I ruptured my Achilles,
I knew what happened.
I knew the severity of the injury and I
didn't know if I was going to come back
from it.
Yeah.
In the locker room you were crying.
I mean,
I didn't like this.
Is it like my career could be over right
now.
So how do you get back from that?
Because you know,
when you talk about injuries,
you know,
people spraying their ankles,
dislocate your fingers,
but a Kaylee's yeah.
People don't come back from that.
Well please don't come back from that to
the level they were before.
I mean,
how,
how is,
how do you get that resilience?
How do you fight that?
Well,
what I did is I went home and I was just
really angry and I'm angry.
I was angry,
was mad,
I was angry.
I worked so hard for us to get to the
playoffs and to have a chance to win
another championship.
And then this happened.
So I had a lot of anger and a then from
the anger and then I was sad.
And then you start feeling bad for
yourself and then you say,
all right,
okay,
I'm done being a baby.
Okay,
what am I going to do now?
Because I can't sit here and give up.
That's not an option.
So now what,
how long was the cycle from this anger?
One night.
It was because you started writing in
the middle,
right?
You wrote that,
uh,
you,
you wrote that and then it was,
okay,
what are you going to do?
So it was,
yeah,
it was one night.
Um,
but then,
you know,
then you start,
it's a process.
You look at process,
what am I going to do?
What can I control surgery.
We'll do the surgery,
come out of the surgery,
recover from their physical therapy.
Okay.
Physical therapy piece by piece,
by piece,
start running back when a court.
And so I broke things down into sections
and said,
okay,
I'm going to focus on resting right now.
This is it.
I'm going to focus on moving my toes and
then walking.
And then you look at every challenge at
every step.
And that's how you're able to be
resilient and come back from these
things.
Because,
uh,
you know,
for your field in a,
in sports injuries often happen,
right?
And to come back.
But you know,
for,
for most everyday people,
it's,
it's something that they can't fathom
because they don't,
they don't have that type of resilience
resistance that they have to face.
Right.
So how do they,
how do they come back from it?
Because sometimes people fail in their
fields and their jobs or at school,
young kids,
you know,
you don't have a good test score,
you don't make the basketball team or
you know,
they have these disappointments.
How do they,
what is your advice to young kids to,
you know,
to,
to face the face,
this adversity.
How do you persevere?
Like if you,
because you,
you have that chemical makeup to fight
through it.
Not all kids do,
but,
but you,
you every kid,
every person has the ability to put one
foot in front of the other one step at a
time.
Right?
So like if you're saying,
okay,
I'm going to climb Mount Everest is at
the bottom of the mountain and you look
up and you go in and I'm not going to
climb Mount Everest,
right?
But if you break it down into sections
and you just one foot in front of the
other one step at a time,
next thing you know you're at the top of
the mountain.
So the the,
the map,
the,
the plan is to set short term goals and
to get there eight to be,
let's see it coming back from my
Achilles.
I came back from the Achilles and I was
fine and then the next year I fractured
my knee.
Right.
Sorry.
Here we go again.
Come back from that next year.
Tear my shoulder.
Here we go again.
Right.
But if I looked at those things in
totality,
it'd be depressing.
But if I look at it as just the facts,
this is,
this is it happened,
can't do anything about it.
It happened.
Now what are you going to do?
One step at a time,
a Keeley's knee,
shoulder.
Any step of the way you said screw it.
Forget it.
Done no more.
No,
never.
No one know your why.
Right?
Because you know,
as time goes on,
I'm sitting there,
I'm 78 years old and I'm going to be
wondering if I could have come back from
this injury.
I don't want to wonder.
I want to find out.
We got to get to that second point.
I want to see you,
man.
We want to get to that game.
The critics are out there saying he's
done.
He'll never come back.
Well,
maybe you're right.
Maybe you're not,
but let's find out.
We got to get there.
Last one to be fearless.
You know,
that's,
that's something that,
uh,
I think every young adult,
young kids,
they face their fears,
right?
What is,
what does that mean to be,
to be fearless?
Why is that such an important part of
the Mamba mentality?
Well,
it makes,
I think the greatest fear that we face
is ourselves.
Actually.
I think it's,
um,
it's not anything that's external or
anything that's superficial.
I think the greatest fear you face is
yourself.
Because you know,
we all have dreams and it's very scary
sometimes to accept the dream that you
have and it's secure.
You're still to say,
okay,
I want that.
It's scary because you're afraid that if
you put your heart and soul into it and
you fail,
then how are you going to feel about
yourself?
Right?
So being fearless means putting yourself
out there and going forward no matter
what,
go for it.
Not for anybody else,
but for yourself,
when you,
when you got to the league,
you were 18,
did you have any fears before getting
there or when you got that right away?
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I had fears that everybody was going to
be right.
I made a poor choice,
poor decision.
I wasn't too,
I wasn't going to amount to anything.
So that was always in the back of my
mind for sure.
And then,
so out of these five pillars,
which one do you think comes first?
Be Passionate,
be fearless,
relentless,
resilient or,
or,
or they just come together.
I'll know it's this funny thing is like
we created the separate pillars,
but the reality is it's all one thing,
you know,
cause it all comes from within.
It comes from within us.
We all experienced these things at
different stages in different points,
different times.
Um,
the key I feel it's just to be aware of
those moments as they occur.
Right?
You're aware of a certain fear or um,
a certain obstacle or challenge,
right?
You're just aware of those things.
And then from there you can navigate
through them.
Um,
but I look at more,
I look at them all as one,
one connecting,
um,
thing because I think pink
being fearless,
this last one sticks out in my mind a
lot because,
uh,
you know,
being an Asia Asian kits,
a lot of times they're little bit more
boxed in,
in,
in thought and mentality as opposed to
western kits,
the lot of the family,
the environment.
You know,
ever since a young age in school,
it's,
it's preaching independence.
Speak your thoughts,
be creative,
independent,
you know,
a lot of that,
it's in,
it's,
it's also reiterated by teachers,
principals,
um,
mothers and fathers and aunts and uncles
and coaches is to bring name to yourself
and to be independent,
to be out there and go on your own.
But in,
in eastern,
in Asia,
a lot of the cultures,
whether it's Chinese,
Japanese,
Korean,
it's,
you know,
don't go out there and do crazy things.
Don't go out of your comfort zone.
Bring,
make your family proud.
You know,
don't,
don't bring other people attention.
Just do your thing.
Do it well,
but don't bring attention.
You know,
it's,
and I think a lot of kids are fearful of
going out of this box,
right?
Is there a vice for these kids?
Because a lot of times it's a cultural
difference.
Sure.
Right?
You know how,
how,
how did,
how did they put themselves out there
when,
listen,
it's very,
so you have to dance beautifully in the
box that you are comfortable dancing.
Right?
So like everybody's box is different.
My box was to be extremely ambitious
within the sport of basketball.
You're box,
it's different than mine,
right?
Every kid here has her own box.
But it doesn't mean that your box isn't
as beautiful as mine.
Right?
Everybody has their own.
It's your job to try to perfect it and
make it as beautiful of a canvas as you
can make it.
And if you have done that,
then you have lived a successful life.
You have lived with Mamba mentality.
So it doesn't mean you have to go out
here and do all of these crazy things.
I'll have to be like this person or that
person.
No.
What are you comfortable being?
What it is that,
what is it that you want to do with your
life?
And once you have that,
then you're trying to live it to the
best of your ability.
So,
you know,
uh,
growing up in Italy and then moving on
to Philadelphia and then to La,
you know,
obviously you talk about this box,
right?
So is,
is that box constantly changing?
Are you trying to get out of your
comfort zone even when you were first
year of the Mba and then 10th year in
the NBA and then even this year,
there's that box that this metaphorical
box you talk about.
Does that change?
No,
I never tried.
I never looked at it as like,
I'm just going to,
you know,
try something completely crazy or like
just,
just go out of my box where thing,
I just looked at it as
I want to be one of the best basketball
players who have ever played.
That's the end goal.
Okay,
how do I get there?
How do I get there?
And every decision I made in my life was
centered around the process of helping
me eventually get there.
You know what I'm saying?
So I had that purpose and once I had
that purpose,
every decision that I made was centered.
Yeah.
Around that purpose.
You think you got there looking back
upon it now,
two decades of Mba,
you know,
high school,
uh,
Italy to high school in Philadelphia to
the Mba.
You spent your whole career with one
organization.
To me,
is that your biggest accomplishment?
To be one team.
Thank you.
Um,
you look back upon it now,
when you had your goals as a kid,
you're five years old,
you wanted to be in the NBA and then
when you're at lower Merion and
Philadelphia and those dreams started to
become,
Eh,
I'm going to get there.
Right,
right.
And then you're in the NBA,
you set goals for yourself.
You talk about all the time when you're
young in the NBA,
you set personal achievement goals.
I'm going to win a game and win and win
a championship.
I'm going to win the MVP,
I'm going to win this,
I'm going to win back.
And then later on you changed because
you said,
I'm just going to get better.
And when I,
if I'm going to get a better left hand,
I'm going to have better three point,
I'm going to have a better free throw.
Those other personal achievements come
naturally.
Now you're done played your final game,
60 points.
You dropped it on Utah,
Mamba Out,
right?
Yeah.
You look back upon it now.
Where do you see yourself?
Did you,
did you do everything you wanted to do?
Did you become the best,
best bass player you can ever become?
Did you become the best?
It's weird like the,
my vision of what my goal is changed
drastically.
As I got older,
I like as a kid I said I want to be the
best ever.
Right?
And now you go through your life and
everything you do is try to be the best.
How would be the best?
That would be the best ever.
And as you get older you start
understanding that those things are very
superficial things and everybody has a
different opinion about it.
No matter what you do,
I can win 20 championships.
There's always an opinion on who's the
best.
Everybody has different opinions.
And so I started really kind of
understanding,
maybe that's not the important thing.
Maybe important thing is to know how do
we as a team grow,
how do I help my teammates be better?
So that was the first change for me.
And then as I got older,
still it became more about,
um,
how are you inspiring others to find
themselves?
That is the ultimate championship.
So won five championships,
that's great.
Another team won a championship this
year,
teams going to championship next year.
Those things come and they go.
But with stays is how do you use your
passion and use that to inspire somebody
else to create their passion and then
how can they pass that on to the next
person?
That is true success.
Um,
so my goals have changed drastically
from the time I was six years old to the
time I was 17 at the time I was 25 and
now sitting here at 37.
So now you left the game of basketball.
We're here in Shanghai.
Uh,
we're going to end our talk today
because,
uh,
we've gone a little bit past our limit,
but I think everybody is very happy to
be here.
And I think they learned a lot about the
member Mamba mentality,
right?
Um,
what's,
what's next for you?
It's,
it's always teaching the game,
teaching the game through various ways.
You know,
it's,
we do camps and clinics,
we do those things and,
but also through storytelling,
right?
How can you,
how can you share stories with the rest
of the world that challenges them to
look internally and,
and to learn things like process and
learn how to navigate the sense of self
and all these things.
How can you infuse into entertainment
and in a way that pushes our culture and
our society forward?
You know,
those are the questions that I'm really,
really intrigued by and that's what
we'll focus on.
Ladies and gentlemen.
One of the greatest of all time.
Koby Bryant.